okay um
i'm gonna share with you my 15 years of
living on skid row
downtown l.a skid row and um
this place is just it's it's just way
out you just you got
so many resources but you got so many
people that just
don't want it you know they've gotten
too comfortable with being on skid row
and it's like this is the life that they
chose
uh a life that i have chose
um you often choose this life when
you feel hopeless and um
not only that it's like it could be a
rush it could be
uh it could be a challenge
it could be really pretty much whatever
you want it to be
um you decide your own fate on skid row
you could be in wrong places at the
wrong time you can
not be an addict and become an addict
overnight
i mean it's just a little bit of
everything that goes on you know
i support myself on skid row by um
i like to say uh performing sexual
favors that's like a better way of
wording prostituting or hoeing
you know i perform sexual favors
this go around it's been around where um
i cannot say
that i have uh
used condoms because it's like uh
this go around i had to go hard in the
pain it's like
this it's nothing like it was
i'll say eight years ago when i was down
here on skid row
and now that i'm back on skid row it's
like
it's almost keeping up with technology
it's like uh
it is uh uh what's the word i'm looking
for it is um
what's that word advancing you know
so it's like uh the price of drugs have
went up
uh the price of [ __ ] has went down
excuse my language
and it's like uh you can pretty much
sell anybody and everything
on skid row you know everything is for
sale everyone's for sale
and it's like uh it's deep
it's really really deep and uh believe
it or not these
are people's lives
here on skid row this is their hometown
they literally
they'll bash your head in you know if
they don't know you
and you're walking certain blocks on
skid row
you know part of it's a paranoia of you
being a police or
or snitch or an informant uh
and part of it is somebody that's about
to retaliate on them
so uh i mean it's just like uh
that saying where they said this is the
devil's playground well it truly is
i'm starting to do things that i said i
would never do
and uh it's mentally bothering me
you know but uh it is what it is um
i um
like i said i'm starting to do things
that i said i would never do
and uh it's like it's it's nowhere
[Music]
of value meaning it's it's not even
worth it you know because at the end of
the day
like i said i'm supporting myself by
working the streets i don't sell drugs
um i don't panhandle
you know i just use what i've got
you know uh i want to say my mom's gift
and god's gift you know so
uh
just never say you'll do something until
that time comes basically that's my
advice to you because when your back is
to the wall
you never know what you'll do and
it's kind of exciting because it's like
for me i know this is not my life so for
the people that
are on the outside looking in it's like
you could think
what you want to think about me because
again i know that this is not my life i
know
what i'm achieving and how i'm trying to
get out of skate roll um
before being kicked out of skid row
believe it or not you can literally be
kicked
out of skid row you can be ran out of
skate roll you can be forced out of skid
row and it's like what the hell
you know but it's some for real for real
stuff so before any of that
should happen you know i'm taking steps
uh to get out of skid row peacefully
hopefully
and and my you know in my right state of
mind
you know um i had a couple of good
friends that uh we used to grind
or hustle as some people call it
together and uh
they got caught up in the mix and it's
just like um
you gotta watch who you hang with who
you roll with who you smoke with
you know because it's like uh
if you're with somebody and they're
known to do foul [ __ ] and they do foul
[ __ ]
boom bam bam if you're with them when
you're when they're smoking when they're
doing whatever
i mean you're gonna you're gonna reap
the consequences that they reap just as
well because in
in someone else's mind it's like either
you had something to do with it either
you knew about it so it's just so easy
to get
caught up in the rapture and the
[ __ ] and the drama
out here oh skid row is nothing but
drama
and [ __ ] you know it's man it's just
misery if you like company
so it's like um
i'm literally like like fed up with
getting loaded because the dope isn't
[ __ ]
you know um
it's it's it's for one thing it's it's
not what it used to be
i know it's nowhere near what it used to
be in the 80s but then when you take it
back to the 90s it's like
half of that so it's like before i blow
my money off on that that i have to go
and you know like i said uh
perform sexual favors or whatever i'd
rather get on my knees to shoot dice and
try to turn my money over that way
or i'd rather eat it all up you know so
it's like it's like you've really got to
be strong-minded to be on skid row to
make it through skid row to be able to
sit here like i am
right now talking to you um
i find myself uh performing sexual
favors in
alleys and it's like
man who's to say i'm gonna make it out
of that alley
you know who's to say that this guy
isn't gonna flip in the midst of
of if we're getting high nine times out
of ten i try not
to let it be that round but sometimes
when
i i need things such as not drugs but
such as food
money to do my laundry because there are
no like resources for free laundry
they give you food but lately the food's
been making a lot of people sick
i mean a lot of people are odd on the
particular drug that i that i do which
is crack cocaine
and it's like dealers are so greedy and
so thirsty
they rather melt down a pill and whip it
up
with something rather than to go out and
purchase at least
a half of i mean i smoke don't if i can
afford
80 worth of dope i know they can you
know but uh
it's just it's it's it's exciting
it's it's not scary because i really
fear no man but god
but it's just
something to just uh really really
reflect on you know you have to be
careful who your suppliers
are you have to be careful of who you
accept free drugs from
i mean one of the things that i i've
done this go around that i said i'd
never do was to
perform sexual favors for drugs and
uh i found myself doing that a few times
this go round
uh for the simple fact
dealers are out trying to make money
they're not trying to spend money
and it's like uh if they get you know
get off with giving up a few dubs then
they'll do it but then the code thing
about it they switch up on you know give
you maybe two rocks that's
you know okay and then the rest of the
ship will be straight [ __ ] so
it's like uh i guess that's what i get
for going against the grain and that was
one of my rules was
not performing uh you know
sexual favors for drugs but i found
myself kind of being desperate
it was enough that i could trade off for
a few things because you get some people
down here their hustle is to
uh they've got somewhere where they get
fast food and it's like
they sell it for a little bit of nothing
for the drugs so i found myself being
desperate like i said
and it was you know enough drugs that i
could smoke
and you know kind of live off of but
uh boy did i have a lot of mad people
you know and it's just like uh
even though it wasn't my fault still
just that easy how i got caught up in
the rapture you know not even knowing
you know so
here it is i'm sitting i'm smoking on
you know rocks that i feel came off the
same
rock when literally it was
you know half and half [ __ ] and real
so i noticed specifically when that when
this guy said you know i'm like you know
dude i really don't feel comfortable
doing that because
i don't know how your product is so i
remember him
specifically shuffling them around and
eyeballing him
to where he knew what he was looking for
but i didn't
so the tester that he gave me was just
like whoa okay
it took me there i'm like okay let's do
this let's you know
so and then i'll say i continue smoking
off that same one and then i kind of
you know traded off a few pieces which
was not off the one that i was smoking
so i had so many angry people coming
back to me saying hey i want my [ __ ]
back
you know this [ __ ] is not uh it's not
real
it's burning up it's uh choking me and
i'm like
bro i'm just getting off the same thing
it was like
hold up swole up in my mind i'm like
wow he did give me a couple of pieces so
here it is this honest person all the
time
i'm finding myself somewhat fibbing
and i'm not a liar because you know my
mom always said if you tell one lie you
have to tell another you have to
remember the other
so i'm getting into a lot of
altercations and i mean
i'm fighting a lot and i'm 42 years old
i'm getting too old for this [ __ ]
yes i was addicted addicted to
to getting the money because the money
was lovely back then
and it was just like um guys paid well
and it was not even a 10 minute job i
mean i remember guys getting to our
rooms
and it would be over within 20 minutes
and it's like oh
you could stay in a room but then that
became a problem because the motel
stopped letting the women stay because
of chaos so it was it was
kind of lovely back then you know um
it was fun back then getting with all
the women us getting dressed getting
ready to go
you know do our thing because during the
daytime though
the the the guys that was in our circle
some boosts um
you know uh did whatever it was they did
and they would you know look out for us
until nightfall came nightfall it was
time for the girls to get out there but
we would all meet up
uh a daybreak you know and everybody had
money everybody had dope
everybody had something new or they
might have thought about somebody and
got somebody new
nowadays you can't even get a bottle of
water from nobody they want to hit or
they want a dollar
and i mean it's like wow
jane will keep you from moving on it'll
stagnate you so
it's like if you're gonna feel ashamed
about anything that you're doing
then my advice to you is not to do it
because uh
shame will stagnate you shame will make
you feel some type of way to where you
can't even process to where you can't
how you say function
so you will constantly be medicating
yourself
you know meaning using
to run from the shame or to hide from
the shame and like i said
these drugs are not what they used to be
so and instead of it altering your mind
the [ __ ] stays there and then it's there
even more
and it's like not only are you feeling
shame you're feeling guilty because
you're constantly smoking or medicating
yourself
and you're not trying to do anything
about the shame so it's like
hopeless sits in self self work
worthlessness
and then all that can either turn into
anger
or it could give you a nervous breakdown
and that's if you have a conscience
you reap what you sow out here um
you think you're untouchable you think
that you're all that you think you're
big and bad well guess what
when karma comes no size
no no no skills karma don't give a [ __ ]
about none of that she's coming and
she's coming
harder than you think and uh you know
it's like i i prefer i prefer
karma as a woman for the simple fact
she's just like a [ __ ] when she comes
and she's coming for that ass
and she wants everybody to know that you
are
reaping karma meaning that she is here
she is present
that you are only reaping what you sow
and
it could be what you thought was
something so small to something
to it could be something you did to
somebody that you thought was no one
well
when karma comes she comes like you
[ __ ] with her child
or something you know and it took her a
while to catch up to you but guess what
she got up to you and she's gonna break
you down and she's gonna make you
realize that hey
look this is karma i'm the one from all
the [ __ ] that you did
and you thought you got away with it
well here i am tough guy
badass or untouchable now what are you
gonna do
so when she's done with you she can
either
leave you speechless meaning dead
or she could give you something a lot of
time to think about
meaning you could wind up in prison for
two to maybe not just the average life
sentence but maybe the
the the the a two-life sentence
because it's like uh depending on what
you've done and depending on
your past your past is gonna
come and meet up with karma and they're
gonna tag team that ass and it's gonna
run for the kind
and you're gonna be through his money
basically she is no joke she is
for real um i can't say i've dealt with
her but i've seen her in action and she
like i'm telling you she is
nothing to play with i advise you to
keep it one highly
be true to thyself uh and you'll be all
right
all that thinking you're gonna make a
quick come up
and it doesn't matter and that person
doesn't matter what you're doing
doesn't matter if it's not true if
you're not getting
your money or your hustle on real i
advise you not to do it because
karma is in the midst of all of that
yeah and that's some for real [ __ ]
discord this [ __ ] right here
now mark whoo it's it's crazy man it's
it's man it's not fun anymore and that's
oh my dear mama this [ __ ] is not fun
thank you yeah it is time to get out